hello everybody
keith burns and davis bailey here with
green cover seed
we're going to give you a quick plot
tour uh we call these this our
overwintering plots davis
tell us a little bit about how the plots
were set up and when they were planted
these plots were planted september 30th
it was
we wanted to focus mostly on the cereals
and the
legumes that we use in over wintering
mixes we tried a few
brassicas mixed in with some clovers and
we didn't see exceptional sand there
just a little bit too late
but again we have the overwintering
cereals and grasses
the legumes here right now we're in the
clovers and we've got
four clovers here we've got
fixation blanca clover kentucky pride
crimson clover right here i'm standing
in the yellow clover
and then we've got the big red clover a
newer variety for
us so several things that we're really
going to stress
and point out as we work our way through
this number one
this was probably planted later than
what we would want if we wanted to try
to establish clovers
and you'll see that the clovers aren't
the greatest thing that we have out here
uh but it's it's a you know in a
september beginning of october
is a realistic time for when uh we would
plant a lot of cover crops
in a typical fall uh the second thing is
we got to record cold levels this winter
i know my thermometer said 34 below zero
one morning so we were extraordinarily
cold
but you cannot tell that from these
plots we had some of the best
overwintering that we've ever had and
that goes to show you how powerful of an
insulator snow
is because when we got that cold we had
probably 12 to 16 inches of snow
really laid nicely across all these
plots and we had
extraordinary overwintering ability in
fact
this crimson clover that i'm standing in
this happens to be kentucky pride
crimson clover
this is probably one of the nicest
stands of crimson clover
we've ever had over winter and i would
say i've probably only seen crimson over
winter here
maybe three out of the last 12 years and
and that tells you
how good that snow was at insulating
things because we would not see this
even in a relatively mild winter with no
snow cover
so the so the crimson clover is
obviously the fastest growing clover
uh it's it's the biggest so far it's got
a really good stand kentucky pride is an
improved version of a dixie type crimson
clover
so i'm excited to see how this looks and
how this works
the bellonsa clover next to it here and
this is not surprising balance is a kind
of a slow starter
it's it's going to look slow but once
it starts growing and kicking in it's
really going to grow fast and it will
overtake this crimson clover and the
amount of biomass produced this spring
we will be out here to give periodic
updates
and show how this is growing and which
one is kind of catching up
uh the yellow blossom too late for it to
really establish so i'm not surprised
that
uh there's not a lot out there there's
there's some it's sporadic it's not the
greatest stand
but again for yellow blossom we would
want to probably establish that
uh the end of august would really be
more ideal on that
and then the red clover a perennial type
clover so it's going to come on it'll
probably fill in
but again a poor stand again just far
far
too late to really get it established
right so
you know sometimes when we do these
plots we want to demonstrate things that
we don't recommend
and and this is why we wouldn't
recommend putting these clovers in this
late
because you're just not going to have
the best chance of success on those
right yeah when we came out here
beginning of march
it's april 15th right now so about a
month ago
i was surprised to see that the only
clover that was visible at that time was
the crimson clover
as you think about it it's not quite as
surprising because if it is the fastest
growing clover which it is
since we had that nice blanket of snow
it
over wintered exceptionally well and so
it makes sense that we see it
with the best stand right here right now
like you said i think we expect that
fixation to kick in a little bit later
we'll come back in a couple weeks and
give you an update on this
okay these next set of plots are winter
peas which again
are not the most reliable overwintering
legume for us but
again with the snow that we had
these are some of the nicest winter peas
that we've had as well davis tell us
what we got planted here
we have three strips here two of the
strips these first two are austrian
winter peas
the first strip is planted at one and a
half inches deep the second strip where
keith is standing is two and a half
inches deep
and then where i'm standing here are our
new wyo winter peas and what depth were
those planted at
they were planted at two and a half
inches and a half also and one of the
reasons that we wanted to plant them
deeper
is that typically to get a winter peat
over winter the deeper you plant it the
better it is
because you got to keep the growing
point under the ground to keep it from
freezing off and so
we would have expected in a normal
winter for these deeper planted ones
to look better than the shallow planted
ones at an inch and a half
but they look fine but again that's
because we had we had the snow
cover and so you know there's there's
maybe some subtle differences i
i think the wild winters maybe look a
little bit nicer a little
more even stand and what the wild
winters are
it is a fairly new variety developed by
the university of wyoming thus the name
uh it is a selection out of austrian
winter peas so they're not going to look
a lot different but they've been
selected to overwinter
uh in cold dry winters they were you
know developed there in laramie wyoming
on the high plains and so
we think that it's going to be a better
pea our growers of these really like
them they like them better than the
regular austrians they have overwintered
consistently now
for three years up in northern nebraska
where one of our growers are at
and so we're pretty excited about them
we think that it's going to be
our winter pea of the future you know
again for right now
if you look davis you can see there's a
number of these plants that have
some some burning on on the
down at the base i'm guessing that some
of the early growth that was out here
probably got cold enough to where it
froze off part of that
but again a win a peak and freeze
everything above the ground
off as long as the growing point under
the ground has not frozen
it will keep growing new shoots out and
so i'm guessing that what we're seeing
is some of the early growth that kind of
got singed a little bit with some cold
weather
but they've grown out of it just fine
and i think they're going to continue to
to grow and
and we've actually behind these trees
over here we have a few acres that we
may
let grow out and see if we can harvest
some of these wild winter peas as well
yeah even where you see the frost damage
you see
new shoots like keith is talking about
but you also see out of that same chute
actually significant growth even though
we've got the brown leaves below it
so right next to the winter peas we have
winter lentils
these are morton winter lentils it's
actually the only variety that i'm aware
of that is a true winter lentil
lentils are in the same family as peas
and vetch
they are kind of the less aggressive
cousin i guess i would say to vetch
we've actually seen pretty good
consistent winter hardiness out of these
winter lentils
and again this year is no exception
pretty good stand
lentils are never going to take over a
plot
they don't vine like a vetch does they
kind of stay a little bit more contained
within themselves
but they're a really good companion crop
you're not going to get great weed
control from lentils by themselves
so we would never unless you're trying
to grow them for seed we would never
want to see you put lentils in alone
but they're a nice companion crop to
other mixes that you would do
so we sell more spring lentils and
winter lentils
but these winter lentils did really well
this year
yeah certainly something to put in a mix
because you can see it establishes
beautifully but if you're wanting to
plant a cover crop primarily for weed
suppression
i certainly wouldn't count on lentils
alone
all right davis now we come to hairy
vetch cherryvatch
know we touted as the most reliable
overwintering of all legumes
and and again we had good snow cover so
a lot of it did over winter
uh but we've got we've got some
interesting things to look at here in
the harry vetches so go ahead and
and tell us what we've got planted here
right next to the cereals there we've
got woolly pod vetch
oftentimes we would consider that here
in nebraska more of a spring vetch
really good drought resistance and we
use it in a lot of places in the country
a lot of different times of the year i
think next to it is spanish vetch and
i'll let you talk more about that one
but then as we get into the true hairy
vetches here
we have a you merit i'm standing in the
montana hairy vetch then next to me is
the winter king and next to that in
between
the winter king and the lentils is
purple bounty
yeah so i'll just kind of compare and
contrast these a little bit so starting
over
uh with the woolly pod like like davis
said it it's
it's actually not a true winter annual
it's a very cold tolerant spring annual
again some of the best overwintering
wooly pod veg that we've seen if you're
going to plant a vetch in the springtime
it's one of the most aggressive fastest
growing biggest biomass vetches you can
plant in the spring
the spanish fetch frankly is a little
disappointing to me this is
hairy vetch that we brought in from
spain
we knew that it probably doesn't have as
good a cold tolerance
and we're seeing that even you know it
has less cold tolerance
evidently than even wooly pod i think
it's going to be a good batch as long as
we keep it further south to where the
winters are going to be more mild it's
definitely a less expensive one
so we're going to just keep it in the
south the two nicest ones
out here by far as we look at the plots
are they are the au merit
in what we call our montana vetch and
and the montana vetch is obviously grown
in montana
au merit is a is a fairly new hairy
vetch
uh it in the previous plots that we've
had it's the best hairy vetch that i've
ever seen
uh we'll see how it does this year i i
say it in the montana are looking pretty
similar right now
we are doing some seed production on au
merit this year we got licensed to be
able to do some of that
so we've never had very good supply of
it so i'm excited to have better supply
of both of these vetches they're both
very aggressive growing they both have
overwintered quite well
eu merit looks a little better right
here in this area but as i look
down uh through the strips i'd say you
know they're they're very similar the
montana bench maybe is even a little
better
right now down that way so we'll we'll
really monitor this
keep an eye on it and then we'll
definitely be collecting biomass samples
of a lot of these as well to see what
kind of nitrogen fixation
production we've gotten in biomass
accumulation
the winter king winter king is a variety
that was developed more for
eastern wet winters where they don't get
as cold but they're going to have more
freeze thaw
cycles that's a little bit different
type of overwintering mechanism needed
i will see if it fills in it it doesn't
look as good as these others right now
there's a stand there it just doesn't
have quite as much growth
and then the purple bounty one over here
uh it's touted as being the earliest
hairy vetch on the market
uh i would predict that we'll see it
bloom earlier than all these others but
we want to keep a really close eye on
that and we'll make good notes
of when we see each one of these bloom
to verify that that really is one of the
earliest maturing vetches on the market
the winter king last year we had it in
our plots
and it looked about the same here in
comparison to the other
vetches but it actually came on these
next few weeks a little bit quicker than
some of the others and so i
expect that one too even though it looks
the furthest behind out of these four
um i'm excited to see that in a couple
weeks yeah that'll be good to see how
they how they doing
over the next several weeks all right
now we come to the king of all cover
crops and that's cereal rye
cereal rye is the most widely used cover
crop
both within green cover seed and also
within the cover crop industry as a
whole
mostly because you it's so cold tolerant
it's so aggressive
growing this time of year in the spring
it just
can't be beat when it comes to that now
we've told many of you
many times that there's a big difference
between l albon rye which is where i'm
standing
and all other types of rye and this is
going to be a great video
to show that we're not just blowing
smoke when we say that
it's actually true this albon ride again
all planted at the same time right at
the very end of september
this elbon right here is you know 18 to
20 inches tall
what we have over here is ryman rye
which is a
would be considered a northern canadian
dakota type rye
it is about 12 to 14 inches
at the most and then where davis is
standing here is our yankee rye
which again is more of that northern
type and it's
it's about i would say it's similar to
the rhyme and maybe just slightly taller
but just elbon was bred for
oklahoma it was bred for maximum
fall growth and very very fast spring
growth
and you can definitely see that if you
want something that's going to give you
the most growth the fastest in the
spring elbon is your go-to rye
davis what's your observations here yeah
if you're wanting
quick growth as soon as possible maybe
you're grazing cattle early in the
spring
elbon is a man amongst boys when it
comes to ryze and all other
all other forage options really
but i think we talked too about how it's
not necessarily just about
early growth or biggest growth maybe
maybe some of these uh
shorter stature options right now um fit
better in a
in a roller crimping situation for
hitting a different window
yeah yeah if you're if you're not
planting corn until the middle of may
this stuff may be too far ahead for you
you may need to go with either a
northern rye or even a triticale which
we'll look at here next
this can get out too far ahead of you
but again for the cattle guy that wants
grazing as soon as possible
man you just can't beat albon for that
and and again it's
you know it's winter hardiness is proven
uh you know could you take it up to
canada and have overwintering every year
i don't know uh but you know certainly
for nebraska
and south and and we're growing it in
south dakota we've got growers growing
albon forests up in the dakotas
so we know it moves north but it's just
hard to beat when it comes to that early
fast aggressive growth
and this will be the first one that will
be to a stage where it can reliably roll
down
as well so again we'll continue to
monitor this and we'll see what the
differences are here in a couple of
weeks
one other note on these ryes you have to
look
pretty hard in these rows to find a weed
whereas in some of the other rows uh
the weeds even from the camera are
probably a little bit more visible
um here there's just a big difference
and it's not just a matter of this being
taller and you can't see them
um it's just significantly better at
weed suppressing
all right now we're in the triticale
plots and i think we've got five
different types of triticale here so
davis go ahead and set the table on what
we've got planted here
next to keith there we have forage fx
right here is thor triticale i'm
standing in the fridge
next to me here is the 813 and then we
have surge
as the last of these five so i'll just
tell you a little bit of the background
on
on all these first of all they all
they'll look great
uh they all came through the winter
really well uh
they're they're obviously smaller
shorter
less growth than the rye uh not
surprising it's what we
would expect you know we're only looking
at uh you know
8 to 10 inches of growth right now but
we know that that's just how triticale
is so
the forage fx 1001
is one of the nicest triticales i've
seen especially as you go from where we
are here in nebraska
and you go north this this thing was
bred in montana
and it's a real workhorse it's it's
truly a
beardless triticale it's going to be a
really beautiful smooth looking crop
when it heads out
and very good growth and and tonnage it
you know again they all overwintered
great because we had that snow cover
had we had more of an open uh ground
when it got so cold
i would have expected this one to look
the best it's going to have the best
cold hardiness of any of these
triticales in my opinion
uh the thor thor is
a brand new one from trical
which we we grow a lot of tri-cal
products
thor is a new one that is fully
facultative and what facultative means
is that it can act as a spring type or
it can act as a winter type so it can
vernalize go dormant and come back in
the spring like it's done here
but we could be planting we're selling
thor to people and they're planting it
right now it does not have to vernalize
in order to give you all the growth
potential that it has
so it's a very versatile one we're
pretty excited about it it's going to be
a replacement for the surge
they look fairly similar it's a newer
type triticale though so it's got better
disease resistances
bred into it so we anticipate this one
being a really good replacement for the
surge that we've had
this is fridge fridge is just kind of
the old school standby
it's a public variety so you know you
may see more people selling it
typically what we see with fridge is
it's always kind of there
but it's never going to yield or have
the performance and i think you can even
see that here
it just it's not as robust it's not as
green it's not as tall
as these other newer type varieties
but if you're not looking to maximize
your forage and you're just looking for
a little bit less expensive triticale
the fridge is not a bad way to go and
then we come to 813
813 has has been our top selling
triticale over the last four or five
years
it's kind of been one of the flagship
products in the tri-cal lineup
we grow and sell lots of 813.
813 is partially facultative so
when you plant it in the spring it's not
going to be as good as thor or surge
but it's going to be better than fridge
or any of the cereal rise for sure
as you move this south it has because
it's partially facultative
it will have more fall growth in the
south and it will get going in the
spring a little quicker than a true
winter type uh like the like the forage
fx
i wouldn't take that one south uh as far
as what i would take 813 or the thor so
again excited to see what this is going
to look like as we grow out a little bit
more
and then of course the surge surge has
been our
facultative or spring treated cayley for
a number of years now
we're going to be phasing that out
because we're replacing it with the thor
all right davis now we're standing in in
the wheat plots and typically we don't
think of wheat
as being as much of a forage crop as
what rye or triticale but these first
two
are our forage wheats they've been
specially
bred to have a lot of forage so tell us
the difference
in the types of wheats that we have here
tell us what we got planted right there
is the t173 wheat
and then here is the willow creek this
may be the later
maturing one so the t-173 is a little
bit taller right now
but i think the willow creek might
actually be tillered just a little bit
more
as from a distance you see it more as a
carpet rather than
being able to see the defined rows with
the t-173
and then over here we've got gore wheat
and hard red wheat yeah so just
real briefly davis is you're exactly
right this is a fairly new wheat the
t173
a forage wheat and actually a lot of
people are growing this one for grain
too it's it's done pretty well
uh these forage wheats especially this
willow creek right where i'm standing
the the place where we would use willow
creek is when we want
a a winter cereal like this
and we want to have grazing as deep into
the late spring early summer as possible
this is the longest maturing
of all of the cereals in this plot and
when we come out here several weeks
later
you're just going to see that this one
is going to look a little slower
it's just because it's got a longer
growing season it will eventually
probably be as big as
many of the ryes and triticales it's
just going to take longer to get there
and so the reason you'd want to do that
is if you're staging your grazing
you would have a willow creek field to
go to last
that would be the main advantage of it
the t173 is definitely going to be a
better fit from nebraska
and south the willow creek may be a
better fit from nebraska and north
kind of kind of yet to be seen willow
creek has montana genetics the t-173
i think is coming from this either
kansas or oklahoma i'm not 100
sure gore is probably one of the most
widely used uh
beardless and by the way these are all
beardless except for this
just regular hard red winter wheat gore
is probably the most widely used
beardless and it's actually a soft red
winter wheat
used in oklahoma and south we put it in
our plots up here not necessarily
expecting a lot
because a lot of years we would see
significant winter kill damage on it
but again with the snow cover we're not
seeing that this year so it'll be
interesting to see
how it grows out and it compares a very
good grazing weed it's widely used
across the state of oklahoma for grazing
and then of course just regular hard red
winter wheat that
you know guys would plant this would be
more of a grain type and not a forage
type so
as these grow we'll be able to kind of
compare growth stages and biomass
accumulations
all right winter oats davis these aren't
supposed to overwinter
here in nebraska we kind of we put them
in every year
just to show people that you shouldn't
plant them this far north if you want
them to overwinter
and again the snow cover is proving us
wrong so we didn't have a great
test of winter hardiness but it goes to
show you if you have snow cover
temperature really doesn't matter we've
got the cossack
black oats here which are very popular
especially in the south it's more of a
forage type oat than a regular white oat
we wouldn't plant these generally in the
spring
we would be planting these in the late
summer and letting them grow deeper into
the winter
excellent forage oat is probably going
to give you more biomass and tonnage
than a
white spring oat overall when planted in
you know that august type time frame
and then bob winter oats is just kind of
an old standby uh winter white oat
they both look really pretty good um
you know i you know we'll see how they
grow the one thing that i
have noticed right here and if you're
looking not nearly as good a weed
control as what we saw over in the rye
plots you just want to make a few
comments on that
yeah i mean maybe it's a little bit of
the allopathic effect
maybe it's a little bit i would say
mostly just because
it's not as full it's not as tall so
it's simply not suppressing the weeds as
well from that standpoint
i think the cossack oats are just a
little bit fuller
filling the road gaps just a little bit
more than we have here in the bob oats
but
like you said last year we had these in
the plots and we had pretty much nothing
winter barley davis tell us what we've
got here
keith is standing in the valor barley
and i'm here in the 919
barley the 919 is probably the one that
we use more of right now
but what do you see for differences in
genetics
yeah you know they look fairly similar
right now
it's a little hard to tell the valor
maybe looks like it has a bit of an edge
but
you know we'll see as they go along
valor is a fairly new one we don't know
a lot about it yet we've
had some production done down in
oklahoma on it it looks pretty promising
919 has kind of been our stand by winter
barley but it's kind of susceptible to
smut
in in the springtime as it grows and
matures so we're looking for something
that maybe has a little better disease
resistance
we don't know valor is that 919 comes
out of the university of nebraska winter
barley breeding program
and i know that they've got some coming
that are going to be replacements for
this
there's lots of winter barleys on the
market out there the thing that make
these two
unique is that they're beardless they're
beardless barleys and if you've ever
seen winter barley
that's not beardless i mean you're
talking about a beard those things have
you know five six eight inch long beards
would be very dangerous to graze
them be would not make very good hay
because of those long
beards and so the only barleys that we
want to offer are going to be the
beardless barleys because
a lot of what we sell goes into grazing
and forage type mixes so
we're only looking at those there's like
say there's lots of other barleys out
there but the beardless ones
there's not that many of all right and
and finally we have
annual ryegrass this is a winterhawk
annual ryegrass which is a example of a
diploid type
which are the most winter hardy of all
annual rye grasses but
annual ryegrasses as a family just are
not going to be nearly as winter hardy
as the rest of
the cereals and you can see that i mean
this actually looks pretty good
for being planted at the end of
september one of the keys to getting
annual rye grass
over winter is getting it established
unlike rye which you can throw out there
in december and it's going to be fine
this time of year
annual ryegrass has to get some root
system established
in order to survive through the winter
and so planted the end of september
is not as good of time as if you could
get it planted early september
in having good rye grass establishment
so you know
for for all things considered this isn't
bad and it will fill in it's it's going
to grow pretty aggressively here
once it warms up it's just not a
it's not as popular especially in drier
areas
because a lot of annual ryegrass has
flown on
in the eastern corn belt because the
rains that they get they can get it
coming up
before they harvest the corn then they
can get that earlier establishment and
they have
a better overwintering success so what
are you seeing here davis
yeah last year again when we didn't have
the
winter cover the snowfall that we had
this year
we didn't see much of this winter hawk
again that's probably mostly timing
as opposed to the plant itself
but pretty decent right here probably
one that we would put more so
in a mix with some other grasses and
some other options rather than counting
on it alone
we really like it for compaction
breaking though and we put it in many
compaction breaking mixes
uh both the diploid and the tetraploid
options yeah it's got a very deep root
system so even though
it's even when we come back out here
later it's going to be the shortest of
all of these
it may still have just as deeper roots
as any of them it's very deep rooting
and that's one of its uh most attractive
features
all right so now we have three
different combinations of albon rye
and harry vetch and i'm assuming this is
probably the montana hairy vetch
it's what we probably most commonly use
here uh and
and we're not going to go into a lot of
detail in this episode we're evaluating
uh what kind of nitrogen production what
kind of weed suppression
and what kind of biomass we're going to
get from different rates of
l bond rye and hairy vet so we've got a
strip here
strip here and a strip over here and you
know as i'm looking at this rye
you know it's it's 18 to 20 inches tall
i i actually i was measuring the other l
but i think it's a little taller
than the other l bond that's over there
and the vetch is significantly
bigger and taller than the monoculture
vetch davis what's your
your initial thoughts on this yeah we've
got the three rates like he said we've
got
20 pounds hairy vetch 20 pounds rye 15
vetch i believe 30 rye and then we've
got
50 rye 10 vetch
yeah it's amazing just seeing the
difference of the vetch
when it's able to have something to
climb it at least looks a lot taller
we'll see if we actually have a
different amount of
biomass we'll do some biomass cuttings
of these
and test the carbon nitrogen ratio we
really liked last year how the
hairy vetch and rye crimped together and
so we'll see
what the results show in a couple months
again very good stands
a little really looking forward to what
we see as these grow out
at the end of every plot we have to have
what we call the vacuum cleaner mix so
davis explain what we've got going on
here
as we're planting these plots we planted
all the grasses first and the legumes
what we do as we're vacuuming out the
drill
that the reservoir is filling up with
all the seeds
we mix that up at the end and then we
plant it and we've got it around the
back side of the strips as well
and it's a great way to just showcase
what happens when we plant things in
diversity because
here we've got all the different kinds
of cereals i see rye grass in here
we have hairy vetch and peas which
again like we maybe saw in the mixes
or the rye and veg combinations it's
just climbing it has something to climb
so it's
it appears taller it fills in
really nicely we even have winter
lentils
and the clovers in here just a little
bit
so it's just beautiful and i think it
provides a lot of good grazing
maybe a little bit more balanced ration
and
this i mean as you look down the road
too it's just
exceptional growth and i think this one
would be
good to take some samples on a little
bit later yeah i mean there's just such
great power and diversity
and again as we as davis said we'll take
the samples
i wish there was a better way we could
sample the roots and the root exudates
and the
biology that's surrounding that
rhizosphere i don't know that we have
the
the technology to to really do that
effectively yet
it's coming i think but we just we know
that this is doing great things for the
soil because of all this diversity
[Music]
you